you can be a history maker or you can be
liked by everyone around you you can't
be both only release Sistine Chapel
ceiling level products to the world your
days are your life and miniature all you
need to do is not worry about the next
week the next month the next year forget
about that that's a waste of time
own your day need motivation what a top
10 with a bully nation
he's Robin Sharma and here's my take on
his top 50 rules for success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one execute your ideas I mean the
reality is reading a book or going to a
conference or having a great
conversation where you get this golden
information that's all fantastic but
what makes mastery is execution on the
ideas not the ideas and so no idea works
unless you're willing to roll up your
sleeves do the practice invest the time
put in the effort do the work I think
we've all observed a lot of people who
they love reading the books they love
showing up at the courses they do all
the online training and nothing ever
changes and they say well you know I
don't know why it doesn't change why my
life doesn't change why my thinking
doesn't change why my performance
doesn't change why my relationships
don't change well it's because ideas
don't work if you don't execute on them
so if you look at the great business
builders you look at any great performer
one thing that makes them great is their
grit one thing that makes them great is
their hunger to practice one thing that
makes them great is they are willing to
sacrifice I mean yes they're passionate
but did you know the root of the word
passion is suffering you've got to be
willing to suffer for your vision you've
got to be willing to suffer to reach BIW
best in world you've got to be willing
to suffer the ridicule and laughter of
your critics and your cynics to get to a
place called world class rule number to
aim for legendary nothing fails like
success you're successful maybe it's in
your health maybe it's in your finances
maybe it's in your career maybe it's in
your family life maybe it's in the way
that you show up in the world awesome
you're in a really vulnerable place
right now it is one thing to be
successful it is another thing to
sustain success over the coming decades
is that it not a powerful idea I mean
let's go to the entertainment
the street it's very hard to be a
one-hit wonder let's not knock a one-hit
wonder but it's even harder to become an
iconic rock band or hip hop band let's
go to the Arts it is very hard to come
up with your Sistine Chapel got it it is
even harder to become a Michelangelo so
are you playing the short game or are
you playing the long game this is rule
number two you know or lesson number two
the life has taught me play the long
game aim for legendary don't just say I
want to be world class in my dominant
pursuit for a little window of time say
I want to have the guts and the grit and
the occupant and the mindset and the
capability and the commitment to create
enduring success and that's why I say
nothing fails like success you look at
the restaurant that is hot in your
neighborhood right now they're on the
path to obsolescence if they're not
really careful sure they went from a
little neighborhood shop that made
beautiful pasta that had great service
that had the owner on the floor shaking
your hand getting to know your name
then they got written up in the
magazines and they then they got
interviewed and then word of mouth
spread like wildfire and what happened
they became arrogant you see success can
be so toxic and it happens it is such a
pull on every human being it just plays
with your mind and you literally shift
from humility to arrogance you shift
from humility to arrogance and once the
arrogance sets in in a mindset it starts
to populate every other person on the
team every other person in the culture
every other person in the community and
it is a very short fall from success to
irrelevance so lesson number two is
nothing fails like success as you become
more successful become more humble as
you become more successful work even
harder as you become more successful
care even more about your product as you
become more successful learn even more
I invite you it when you are the the
Titan of your industry be sitting in the
room
with 18 year olds beginning their game
when you are the the icon of your field
be the person who is up not a five
o'clock anymore let's play at four
o'clock reading listening to the podcast
writing in your journal setting your
goals focusing on your intentions as you
become more successful be more humble as
you become more successful be even more
punctual as you become more successful
become even more passionate as you
become older become even younger
yesterday I was walking on the street
and I met this man in his 80s he said
Rob and I finally retired he's probably
close to 90 and he is a legendary
clothier in the country that I live in
and he just retired and he started his
shop which is now an empire in 1954 so I
don't know what that is but that is
decades and decades and decades and
decades and he did not want to retire he
just retired but he is still on fire to
do amazing things
age is just a number do not let an old
person into your body nothing fails like
success rule number three create a one
page plan number three unbelievably
important which is the importance of
scheduling you know I talk a lot of a
lot about having a dream having a plan
you know being inspired but all ideas
don't work unless you do the work and
some of the best work you can do is
getting really good at creating a one
page plan have your big five the five
things that need to happen this year for
this to be your best year yet on a one
page plan your top five values put them
on that same plan your top five sub
goals sequenced into each quarter of
this year on that one page plan and
every morning while your competition or
the rest of the world is asleep get up
at 5 a.m. I'll teach you how to do that
in future videos but look at your one
page plan to spend twenty minutes on
that so it becomes a brain tattoo a
burning obsession so it all lights you
with inspiration so you go up in the
world and you understand the clarity is
power and you so intimately know what
has to happen during this day
week this month this quarter this year
to get you closer to your mountain top
because the ordinary though the hours
that ordinary people waste extraordinary
people do because they're not bored like
most people most people need to medicate
themselves with too much TV
too much Facebook too much video too
much chitchat too much busyness because
they don't know their goals because they
don't have a one-page plan because they
don't have a one-page schedule I mean
I've got my schedule for every seven
days almost everything I need to do goes
on it and you might say Robin well
that's a very rigid way to live no it's
a very free way to live because then I
have the power to live life on my own
terms
I feel inspired I'm not wasting each day
I'm leveraging each day remember four
become outrageously enthusiastic a
fourth point become outrageously
enthusiastic and again you're going to
say Robin let's hold hands and sing
Kumbaya you know being enthusiastic is
an important next thing you're gonna
tell me is get up in the morning a look
in the mirror and saying I think I am I
think I am above I like myself I like
myself I like myself I like myself but
isn't it true that the most enthusiastic
person in the room influences people and
they elevate people and they encourage
people another issue of Fortune magazine
a little while ago did a did a story on
Richard Branson's Necker Island
conference he invited all sorts of
amazing people and the reporter in the
room said something I've never forgotten
the reporter said it was striking to me
how in each of the conference sessions
the moguls of these giant firms were
always the most enthusiastic people in
the rooms
it's amazing to me when I meet
world-class CEOs they are the most
humble the most passionate they're the
most in
they're the most lively people in the
room
I think it's fundamentally important to
be the most enthusiastic person you know
I think it's so many ways leadership is
about inspiring people by your example
also if you want to learn how to have
more confidence check out my 254 series
it's free the link is in the description
below and so stop resisting I encourage
you stop resisting the natural flow of
epic performance stop resisting the
natural seasons of life what are the
real reasons we don't do the things that
frighten us is because we are afraid of
being judged and so to become fearless
why not find some time every day to
practice becoming fearless rule number 5
being instrument of service it goes back
to to my dad you know and he was very
much about humility I mean he's 77 right
now and he he gets up every morning and
he goes off to his medical practice and
he still sees patients all day and he
said in I said dad why are you still
doing that at 77 he said because my
patients need me and so I think you know
one of the core values he was so
brilliant and sharing with me is to be
an instrument of service and I think the
moment your ego runs your brain and the
ego runs your business and the ego runs
your way of being then your your gifts
and your talents and your focus and your
capabilities are off the creativity and
the talents and the service that will
make you great in the world and I think
it gets to a very philosophical point if
I may
yeah I think it's relevant to any leader
any entrepreneur any business builder
any game changer well you know I mean
there is such an addiction to the shiny
toys that the ego sells us okay and in
society and the matrix and our peers and
the world says if you get a Ferrari if
you get if you sell 10 million books if
you have lots of money in the bank if
you have you know the beautiful partner
in the big house then you're going to
wake up every morning and look in the
mirror and you are going to feel full of
joy and peace and feel you're fully
alive
and you know I've had most of those in
my life at a pretty exponential level
have been very blessed and not one of
those things has provided me with
enduring sustainable happiness and
fulfillment and the things that provide
me with just deep happiness and deep
fulfillment and energize me all come
from a position of inner power and so
you know at the events you're talking
about
I don't derive much power from all the
books I've sold or bestseller I don't
care about that stuff I really don't I
care less about that than ever before at
the end of the day we are a bunch of
people on a little planet in a huge
galaxy and before you know we're gonna
be a bunch of dust and the great
billionaires get buried next to the taxi
drivers and the pizza makers and we are
not that big a deal and I think all that
really matters is while we are alive you
know do your best to use every day as a
vehicle to birth your talents into the
world and secondly if you do that you're
going to serve the world and raise the
world with you and and that all just
comes from inner power I mean that's
just deriving your power from the place
within you know that's where you get
grace and that's where you get great
creativity that's where you get
boundless energy because it's not about
addicted to what the world thinks of you
rule number six accept failure yeah I
think failure is the highway to success
and I know that sounds like a platitude
but Society or people teach us right
they say oh if you fail and feel
uncomfortable you've done something
wrong and what I try to do in all of my
books and my presentations and my tweets
and is them you cannot get to the
mountaintop without taking a few
missteps and so a business that wants to
win you have to out fail your
competition and as human beings you know
failure is not a bad thing you know ask
yourself what's the opportunity from the
failure you're in get in the game
because when you get to the last hour of
your last day it will not be the
failures you regret it'll be all the
risks you didn't take rule number seven
raise your standards we become our
standards in many ways if you are
surrounded by B players or average
performers the and that is your standard
then your mindset will operate at the
standard that is that is offered to you
by the people around you I mean we do
become our social orbit and if you are
at a standard internally I want to be a
game changer in my field I want to be
BIW the best there ever was I want to be
the van Gogh and the Rembrandt of
Technology or whatever field you play in
then your behavior always matches your
internal identity and your inner
standards so your standards are
important your standards for your
friendships your standards for the
quality of the work you do the standards
of your languaging the standards of the
nutrition you put into your body the
standards of your love life the
standards of your mindset the standards
of the way you occur in the world and so
my invitation for you regardless of what
you do is that you raise your game to a
place called world class and that is all
about being a game changer now I should
caution you and I don't like that word
because language is so powerful and
caution is a word that really is a
little dramatic but I want to caution
you which is as you leave the herd and
the crowd and perhaps the cult of
mediocrity and rise to being a game
changer it's a very disruptive act and
you actually threaten the masses of
people around you and that's why every
visionary was first ridiculed before
they were revered and I'm sure you've
experienced it you want to set you say
you know I want to take my fitness to a
whole new level of world class hour I
want to take my craft to a whole new
level of world class or maybe you're
raising your game financially and then
you share with those you love or your
friend your friends and maybe your
friends are those you love and they
laugh at you and how many times have we
given up on a dream because we were
mocked by the people around you and all
I'm suggesting to you is when you get
laughed at and ridiculed and what people
don't understand your next level of
world class that just means you've got a
great dream and that just means you're
on the path of growth so be a game
changer rule number eight run the twenty
twenty twenty formula I run what I call
the twenty twenty twenty formula I sure
do
and and you know many people around the
world have found great value from him
and it's pretty simple I mean it sort of
rolls back to what the Spartan warriors
once said and they said the the person
who sweats more in training bleeds
lessen war and whether you're an
entrepreneur whether you're an artist
whether you're a baker whether your yoga
teacher whether you're a mom whether
you're a street sweeper you know you
when you walk out in the world there's a
call on your life to bring your best
game to the world and release as much
talent as possible and a lot of people
what they do is they get up every
morning and they sort of run their day
by default and they're chasing the day
and they let life act on them in a very
reactive way and so I think what we want
to do is see ourselves as as warriors of
some sort where we take from 5:00 to
6:00 every morning and we prepare
ourselves mentally physically
emotionally and spiritually and so to
give a tactic to your to your many
listeners it's the 20-20-20 formula
first 20 minutes as soon as you get up
5:00 to 5:20 intense exercise and that's
gonna do a whole bunch of things you
know a lot of my work is very
science-based
and it's gonna create a pharmacy of
mastery so you're gonna release dopamine
which is the the motivational
neurotransmitter you're gonna reduce
cortisol in your brain which is the fear
chemical you're gonna release serotonin
which even if you're cranky you start to
feel good you're gonna release B the NF
which scientists are calling Miracle
Grow for the brain which actually allows
your brain cells to repair from stress I
mean this is exciting to me yeah that's
right so that first 20 minutes you
rewire your brain what else do you do
you jumpstart your metabolic rate what
else do you do you prepare yourself for
resilience against dress and it just
goes on and on second part of the
20-20-20 formula you plan you pull out a
journal you can do it an imprint of your
day which is very powerful or you can
look at your big five or your your plan
that releases hope it releases focus
right because an addiction to
distraction is the death of creative
production Tony okay and then the final
part of the 20/20 formula learning I
mean he or she who learns the most wins
what made Steve Jobs Steve Jobs or an
Elon Musk is they know more
anyone around them and so I believe that
you know the more you know the more you
can achieve and there's great value
investing as much money as you have in
two audio books or programs like you do
at the genius you know the 25k
conference and the genius Network or
whatever it is but you know every
quarter I make sure I get out of my
office and I go off to a conference I
invest a lot of money in learning and
training and coaching and that's the
20-20-20 formula rule number nine small
wins matter small wins matter I mean we
sometimes think that an epic life occurs
one Sunday Sunday Friday afternoon when
the stars line up and something
revolutionary occurs and what I'm
suggesting to you with great love and
great respect is a great life is built
not by revolution a great life is built
by evolution small and steady wins the
race what you do every day is far more
important than once you what you do once
every decade I want to really think
about that idea what you do every day is
simply your life in miniature and as you
live every single day so you're crafting
your life what you do over the next hour
is is really building your future and if
you can just get and I can just get
every single pocket of 24 hours right as
best as we humanly can the rest of our
life is going to take care of itself
so small wins matter you know the moment
in front of the customer where the pull
was to go average and you become merch
enough Wow
sets you up for the next day of a way of
being of WoW the little win with your
family when you feel like watching TV
set you up for another win the next day
a little win of getting up at five
o'clock and running your morning routine
sets you up for a habit of a 5 a.m. Club
morning routine small daily improvements
over time will lead you to stunning
results tiny wins are the way to
greatness and that's one of the things
life has taught me when you look at the
great companies whether it's an Amazon
whether it's
you know some of the some of the tech
startups coming out right now whether
it's a Zappos whether it's a FedEx
whether it's a Nike whether it's a
General Electric whether it's some of
the you know the little shops in your
neighborhood that we really admire
because people still cook the food would
love or they serve the food would love
or people have an attention to detail
great companies are built by those small
steady optimizations every single day if
you look at any great product it wasn't
just one day that built the great
product it was a culture and a mindset
of daily innovation and optimization
when done consistently over time which
led to world-class even-even
relationships a great relationship it's
all about those small daily wins when
done consistently leads to a lifetime of
love I was walking in the woods last
week and there were these there was an
elderly couple walking in front of me
and they really stood out because they
were moving fast hence and they were
also like they had these ski poles and
so this I mean this is the autumn in my
hometown and they were walking with
these ski poles and so I started joked
as I walked by them because pretty much
only the three of us in this deep forest
and I said you're missing the cell and
they sort of laughed and we actually
walked for about half an hour and we
started going pretty deep and they said
to me you know we've been married 52
years and I said 52 years what's your
secret and the woman says well we've
I've had to put up with a lot which made
me laugh and then it was all about the
little small daily things they did to
foster a lifetime of love rule number 10
stop making excuses I was in
Johannesburg a little while ago and I
went through the the airport and I went
into the men's room or washer room or
bathroom however you want to call it and
so I walked in it to the men's room and
the first thing I hear is welcome to my
office and this was the janitor at the
Johannesburg men's room that's funny
hoo-hoo janitor eyes are all make up a
word cleaned the
the toilets like Mozart composed music
now that man has no money that man
probably has very little education that
man is judged by the world as having an
unimportant job and that man is a hero
could be here two millions of people why
because he actually saw himself as an
ambassador to South Africa and his
passion was was palpable and his
visceral commitment to doing work at the
highest level was like you don't see
even from the CEOs and all I'm saying is
even the person in the with the broken
heart the person who's down on their
knees whether they see it or not they
have a choice to rise above their
circumstances and leadership and
humanity is a testament to the people
who have done it I mean you read read
the group you look at Mandela you know
27 years in imprisonment when his son
died he wasn't allowed to attend the
funeral of his own son he said that was
the one of the great pains of his own of
his life and what did he do the victim
looks at something like that torture and
says I am broken and they give up and
they spend that they closed their heart
they closed their mind they closed their
creativity and they blame the rest of
their life on what happened to them but
Mandela what he chose to do was to use
it as an opportunity because actually
the things that break your heart if you
choose can open your heart and adverse
fear the world says fear is bad fear is
only an opportunity for bravery training
and what he did was he used those 27
years of torture to open his himself
mentally physically emotionally and
spiritually to the point where when he
was released and became the president of
South Africa he invited his jailers to
sit in the front row at his inauguration
and he was asked why and he said because
if I don't I'm still gonna I'd still be
in prison and that's a long way of
saying but you know we do make excuses
because we are very good at
self-deception because if we actually
had to face the responsibility of
playing with our bigness in the world
we'd have to let go of our addiction to
our excuse
and and leave what's safe am I making
sense orally no you're told you have to
leave what's safe I mean we are addicted
to crisis sometimes it makes no sense we
are addicted to pain and we'd have to
actually leave the pain to go out to the
possibility of pleasure and joy and
greatness and believe it or not that
frightens us right so we make these
excuses and then we blame people Oh Jo
or Robin I don't like the way he looks I
he he speaks differently but
subconsciously as you're suggesting
those are just our protective mechanisms
to avoid owning the responsibility of
our brilliance rule number 11 have
eccentric vision every genius
entrepreneur has an eccentric vision so
their possibility Rian's they are the
people who said you know well here's the
way the industry has always been and
here's the way the status quo is but
here's what we're going to do what's
coming to the top of my mind right now
as I record this is uber so you've got
Travis Cal meuk and literally through
that single app I mean they don't own
any taxis they don't own any cars they
don't really have any inventory but
through that single app uber disrupted
the entire industry of that level of
Transportation and so you know these
people these genius entrepreneurs come
up with a ridiculously disruptive idea
that is absolutely eccentric in its
vision and that's why people call them
crazy and I'll simply say to you if your
vision is not routinely called crazy
then perhaps your vision isn't big
enough and disruptive enough and we
changed the world when we change the
game rule number 12 believe in yourself
and Bono is sharing the story that I
believe he heard and it was the person
walks inside Kanye West's living room
surveys the living room and cannot
believe what's on one wall of Kanye
West's living room and it's this giant
poster of Kanye West and so the person
who's in the living room goes Kanye it's
a beautiful living room but why do you
have
massive poster of yourself in your own
living room
and kindly replies well if I don't
believe in myself no one's gonna believe
in me and my take on that insight is
simply this no one's going to believe in
your lofty vision no one is going to
embrace in a roll in your mighty mission
if you don't viscerally believe in it I
mean no one's gonna believe in you
unless you believe in you and Kanye you
know in many ways is a disrupter in his
field and Kanye in many ways is playing
it mastery in terms of his craft but
that's coming from this incredible self
belief and yes I understand some people
will say he's arrogant and I in no way
am encouraging anyone to be arrogant or
vain but the larger point for you and I
as people on the rise to mastery and
creating lives that are legendary it's a
really dial in on that insight which is
you know what we really do have to have
the confidence to believe in ourselves
because a lot of time as a leader a lot
of time as a business builder a lot of
time as a craftsperson we will be in the
wilderness we will have an idea for a
business or a product where the rest of
the world says that's impossible and we
have to be coming from a place from
within where our I can is larger than
our I can you absolutely must do the
interior work required where you have
these fiery levels of confidence where
when the world is saying you know what I
dismiss your vision or that is
impossible you have to be that lone
voice who goes no you know what it is
possible and just watch me do it rule
number 13 do one thing well may have
read my book the monk who sold his
Ferrari sometimes I speak about Ferraris
because I don't have a Ferrari but I
love the way that Ferrari rolls and
here's what I mean by that
a Ferraris in many ways mobile art on
four tires a Ferrari in so many ways the
distillation of Enzo Ferraris philosophy
on
a Ferrari in so many ways is a reminder
to you and me about what world-class
stands for and what I want to really
dial into today is this did you know
that every year
Ferrari only produces 7,000 Ferraris and
the point of wisdom or the powerful idea
I want you to really think about and
deconstruct in your journal tonight
after this mastery session is why go
really wide when you can be singularly
deep I'm gonna repeat that again but a
great company and a great performer goes
really really deep on one or two things
and that's how you rise to iconic we
live in a world I call it the cult of
superficiality
addicted to distraction afflicted by
interruption so we take the Trinity of
our performance assets our mental focus
our physical energy and our willpower
those are the three primary assets of a
world-class producer and we diffuse them
we disperse them around thousands of
projects lots of little things and yet I
think of the 7,000 Ferrari philosophy
you know they are world-class and in
terms of producing iconic automobiles
vehicles but they don't want to be that
they don't appeal to everyone they don't
produce hundreds of thousands of
vehicles they want to do a few products
they want to bring out a few things but
do them really really well and that's
really the craftsmen's mindset that's
how craftsmen think or craft to women
it's do a few things but do them really
really well you are an artist my
invitation to you is to produce poetry
in terms of your work that the world
reveals as mastery you know and that is
really all about bringing a rigor to
your game it's not about doing a lot of
things it's about doing one thing well
because the secret of genius is not
complexity the secret of genius is
simplicity you look at any genius
entrepreneur you look at any genius
producer you look at an a genius athlete
they're not doing five sports they're
doing one sport incredibly well and then
putting in the training time to be mono
maniacally focused so that they couldn't
become otherworldly brilliant at their
one thing and I guess what I'm
suggesting to you ultimately is this
think about the 7000 Ferraris philosophy
and if you are a business builder let's
say you're a startup entrepreneur let's
say you're a fortune 500 manager let's
say you're a professional athlete
because a lot of professional athletes
are watching these mastery sessions
let's say you are a mother or father or
yoga teacher or a chef what are the few
things that you could actually do in
your work so that you take all of your
mental focus your physical energy and
the willpower that you wake up with
every single morning and you really mano
maniacally focus those Trinity of
performance assets on the few things the
few projects that when consistently
iterated and improved everyday over time
will allow you to reach a place where
the world calls you world-class and if
you can not only get this idea on the
7,000 Ferraris philosophy but apply it
so it becomes a way of being
you really will own your game rule
number 14 act now when I was growing up
my dad took out this poem and he
translated it from sons griffon to
English and it was a poem from the
Bengali poet Rabindranath Tagore and
allow me to share it with you it simply
said spring has passed summer has gone
and winter is here and the song I meant
to sing remains unsung for I have spent
my days stringing and on stringing my
instrument and my brother and I used to
look at it every morning before we go
off to school but I never really
understood it and so when I got a little
older I said dad you know that poem you
had on our refrigerator door what was it
all about and my dad looked at me said
he said Robin that was a poem written by
a man whose
heart was filled with regret over a life
half-lived he said Robin that was a poem
written by a man who postponed his life
he always wanted to do something special
he always wanted to do important work he
always wanted to be loving in the world
he always wanted to be creative he
always wanted to see the world but he
got busy being busy are you being busy
being busy have you lost that connection
to the life you wanted to live when you
were a little kid are you so busy
stringing your instrument that the song
that your life was meant to sing has
died or is dormant within you and my
challenge to you is simply this to do
whatever it takes before you sleep
tonight to reconnect with the best
within you that you may have lost
because one of the things I've noticed
is this there are too many amongst us
walking the planet today who are sort of
in a waking sleep they have lost a sense
of who they truly are and your life will
never work if there's a huge space
between who you truly are and the person
you know you're meant to be your life
will never be flooded with energy
creativity productivity and happiness if
there is a large space between your life
right now and your unlived life and my
request and encouragement and challenge
to you is truly that you make things
happen so that the person you are
starting tomorrow is more of who you
know you truly are it makes me think of
George Bernard Shaw he was asked on his
deathbed what would you do if you could
live your life over again and he replied
after a long pause I wish I could become
the person I know I was meant to be and
I suggest to you it's never too late for
you to become the person you've always
wanted to be
but don't postpone it for next year
don't postpone it for next month start
being that person that human being that
creative force that business builder
that mother or father that athlete that
humanitarian that force of good that you
have always wanted to be beginning right
now rule number 15 rise to mastery
you can be a history maker or you can be
liked by everyone around you you can't
be both I mean the very nature of living
your personal greatness and doing
something otherworldly in our world of
ours means you're gonna have to think
differently from the majority you're
gonna have to install the habits and
routines that most people don't do
you're going to have to live talk
breathe walk work produce create in a
way that most people who are
card-carrying members of the cult of
mediocrity just don't buy into when you
look at most people out on the world
today and this is not judging this is
just reporting but they're addicted to
entertainment they love gossiping
they're negative they're toxic anyone
who wants to do anything great they want
to bring them down they dismiss the game
changers and they're just coasting
through life and so the very nature of
you stepping up your game living your
greatest potential owning your craft
dominating your field and living a life
that's alleged during means you're gonna
have to leave the 5% and make a decision
to live as very few people do and what
does that mean it means you're gonna be
laughed at it means you're gonna be
ridiculed it means you're going to be
misunderstood because leadership is a
lonely sport and it means you just might
be hated and so there is great value
when people start to hate you because if
you look at jay-z I mean I was reading
his biography and he said you know I
really knew that I was having influence
in the popular culture when people
started hating me if you look a lot of
the great authors when their books go to
number one globally a lot of the
amateurs actually start to say oh that's
garbage I could put them down I watched
a documentary last night on Steve ao Lee
the famous EDM electric dance music DJ
who's getting so much traction in the
world right now and he was talking about
some of the comments that he sees in the
social media and it was things like
garbage and you know boring and
music and whatever even though he's so
skilled I mean you just watch the
documentary called I'll sleep when I'm
dead and you just see the skill and you
can just look at any great athlete and
you can look at any great scientist you
could look at any great chef you could
look at any great artist you can look at
any great author you can look at any
great statesman you can look at any
world-class stateswoman anyone who has
done something and an exceptional level
breeds cynics and dismisses so the point
is simply that's the very nature of
doing something that very few people are
willing to do means that the majority
will laugh at you why because deep
inside they know they have the
opportunity to do something great too
and your example makes them feel guilty
and all I'm suggesting to you with great
love and respect is simply this you do
have a choice you can listen to your
haters you can be one of the haters you
can join the victim heard you can
dismiss people who are doing great
things or you can reach into yourself
and ask yourself this fundamental
question what I want to stand for for
the rest of my life do I really want to
rise to mastery do I want to get to the
last hour of my last day and know that I
took every ounce of the human potential
I was blessed with and through easy
times in difficult times I brought it on
and every as a result of my values my
mindset my heart set my habits my
routines my disciplines I was I owned my
game and I modeled possibility and I
served lots of people and I built a
great lifestyle and now it's the last
hour of my last day and I'm surrounded
by my loved ones and even though people
threw stones at me I took those stones
and rather than being knocked down I
constructed
a monument of mastery that stands as my
legacy and if you live like that you'll
be one of the great ones which is my
greatest wish for you
rule number 16 over the liver we're in a
restaurant the server generally gives
you what you expect or less than what
you expect you go into a clothing store
it's what you expect or less than what
you expect you do business with any
organization it's generally delivering
on what you expect but more often even
less so you have a gorgeous opportunity
to lead the field in everything that you
do by doing one thing practicing every
single day because it's a muscle the
ritual of over-delivering don't just
give your customers what they expect
give them 10x more than what they expect
don't just give your organization what
your manager what your boss what the
organization is expecting from you show
something that is so rare in today's
economy initiative initiative so you're
asked to do a project give them five
more things than they expect you're
asked to give a presentation on
something go the extra mile
consistently dial in the daily habit of
over delivering on people's expectations
and guess what you become a merchant of
Wow you become indispensable to your
organization I wrote a book a little
while ago called the greatness guide and
one of the chapters talked about the
importance of being indispensable and I
learned that when I was a young lawyer
and I remember talking to my mentor and
I asked my mentor you know the top
litigator at this firm how come he is
the icon of the legal profession in this
region and my mentor looked at me and
said Robin
because that person is indispensable to
this firm well how do you do that by
practicing the ritual of over delivering
every single day for the rest of your
life rule number 17 be yourself be
yourself everyone else is taken
well that really speaks to the power of
being an original it speaks to this
concept of authenticity being yourself I
mean we live in a world where there has
never been so much of a seduction to be
like everyone else
there's never been so much influence and
hypnosis through the social media and
through society to talk in a certain way
to walk in a certain way to buy certain
things to measure your success by the
same philosophy and what I'm encouraging
you to do based on this Oscar Wilde
quote is to be yourself I mean talk your
talk walk your walk take the time to
reflect on your dream be true to your
own values because life's greatest
heartbreak is self betrayal rule number
18 don't get stuck in victimhood make
your I can more important than even your
IQ now you're saying Robin what are you
talking about right here well a lot of
people get stuck in victimhood versus
leadership by the seduction of saying
well I'm not smart enough I'm not
intelligent enough well you are
intelligent enough what's even more
important is your mindset of possibility
you see if you look at the best athletes
in the world the best musicians in the
world the best entrepreneurs in the
world the best managers in the world the
best CEOs in the world the best coders
in the world the best pizza makers in
the world the best moms and pops etc etc
those who get elite level results are
not the most intelligent or naturally
gifted people in their field but these
are the people that have that mindset of
possibility and it's all about I can and
that might sound like a bit a bit of a
platitude you know having an attitude if
I can a mindset of possibility a
mentality of legendary but when you
really deconstruct it it's really true
rule number 19 develop a good morning
routine the way you begin each day sets
up the way you live each day I mean the
Spartan warriors set it so well sweat
more in training
leave lesson wor and if you want to be
literally undefeatable in business
literally unstoppable in life you really
want to dial in your morning routine and
so you want to do things like starting
the day sweating because that releases
BDNF brain-derived neurotrophic factor
that repairs brain cells from stress you
want to sweat because that's going to
increase your metabolic rate which is
going to give you energy and we live in
a world where energy is even more
valuable than intelligence you want to
in your morning routine take the time to
write in a journal so you actually can
detect your values reconnect with your
goals each day get to know yourself even
more because awareness is the beginning
of transformation and you want to get
your morning routine right so you take
some time at the front end of your day
to learn because as you learn more you
know you're gonna achieve more and as
you understand better you can achieve
larger rule number 20 stay connected to
your mortality for the past number of
years I've been reading obituaries and
you might say Robin that's negative and
I don't think it's negative I think it's
really positive because I think few
things are as powerful to wake you up to
remind you about what's most important
to fuel your energy to get you into the
game so you let go of your fears and you
do what you need to do to get big things
done then connecting to your own
mortality when you realize that every
single day could be your last
or when you appreciate that no matter
how long you live
life is a short ride you just sort of
let go of the fears and you let go the
limits and you'll live full-on and you
sees opportunities and you have real
conversations with real people
and you sort of wear your heart on your
sleeve and you bring on the fullness of
your authenticity and you do whatever it
takes to get your loftiest dreams to get
done and so I read these obituaries and
it reminds me about what life is all
about and relatively recently I've
started walking in cemeteries I was in
Mauritius a little while ago it's
if you've been delicious but it's this
paradise on earth it's this tiny island
about 4 hours off the coast of Cape Town
and I've been delicious a number of
times I was there to give a big
leadership event you know I talked about
leading without a title so it was filled
with iconic CEOs and people running big
industries and big companies and
entrepreneurs and startup people and it
was really wonderful but I also took
about a week and a half just to refuel
and to work on my new book and to
reconnect with my values and to set
myself up for the coming months and one
of the things I did was I went for a
long walk I love walking I find
interesting like I find a lot of the
most creative people and most productive
people in the planet they all have one
thing in common they have the routine of
walking on a regular basis and so I love
walking I've walked in nature for many
many years and so here I am in Mauritius
and I just started walking and I was
actually listening to an interview of
Charlie Rose and Steve Martin and it was
done in New York in front of an audience
of a few thousand people it was about an
hour and a half long and Steve Martin
was talking about his career and Charlie
Rose is one of the great interviewers of
our time so he was asking about how he
became so good at what he did and his
life and his love of art and stand-up
comedy and acting I mean he Steve Martin
became an actor after a stand-up
comedian etc and so I'm walking and the
Sun is setting and I'm walking along the
Indian Ocean and I'm looking at the
flowers and I get to this little village
and it's this really um you know this
little village with a lot of character
and as I'm walking along the edge of the
village still close to the seaside I
spot a cemetery and I learned to follow
my instinct more than ever before
because instinct is more powerful than
reason and life will lead you to an
interesting place if you stay with the
flow and so I walked towards the
cemetery
and I walked into the cemetery and I
started walking through the cemetery
very respectfully and carefully what it
was interesting to me because a lot of
the tombstones were just made out of
wood and somewhat sadly some of the
wooden crosses were actually really
really small and you could tell that the
grave sites were of kids and as I walked
through the cemetery I saw these crosses
and I saw some tombstones some looked
very old a few graves look fresh and it
reminded me really about the shortness
of life
I mean Marcus Aurelius has written one
of my favorite books the meditations of
Marcus Aurelius and actually he didn't
write it Marcus Aurelius was a Roman
Emperor and during a long military
campaign in his journal he wrote his
thoughts and his philosophies and
someone found those Diaries those
journals and made them into this book
called the meditations of Marcus
Aurelius and he does talk about the
shortness of life and so does you know
epic Titus and a lot of the great stoic
philosophers and being in this Cemetery
and walking through it with great
delicacy it reminded me how short life
is and it reminded me we all have hopes
and dreams and we never know when those
dreams are going to get dashed and you
know we never know what our last day
will unfold some people wake up tomorrow
morning they'll get in their car you
know they'll take a shower they'll have
their coffee they'll say goodbye to
their loved ones and that would be the
last day that their loved ones will ever
see them you know some people on the
planet the day after tomorrow will go
into their doctor's office to get the
result of a routine checkup and the
doctor will say sit down I've got some
sad news for you and will be diagnosed
with maybe some kind of a terminal
illness I mean accidents illness tragedy
catastrophe is also a reality of
humanity it
so what I'm suggesting to you is do
whatever it takes to be in the moment
and to stay positive and to stay on your
game and to optimize your craft and to
spend time with your loved ones and to
take care of your fitness and to learn
something new every day and to enjoy the
beauty of sunsets and star-filled nights
and at the same time as much as possible
please do not lose perspective stay
connected to your mortality
you know Steve Jobs in that famous
Stanford speech said it really well you
know you are naked you have nothing to
lose and he learned that when he
connected to his cancer and so maybe you
will install a ritual once a month on
the way home from work you will pull
over to a cemetery and you'll spend five
minutes even in meditation looking at
the tombstones looking at the crosses
studying the graves or whatever your
tradition is in whatever nation you're
from because not every tradition I know
has the grave site sometimes it's the
the funeral pyre which really reminds me
that life is really short and you never
know when your last day is going to be
and so just build some kind of a routine
to remind you on the shortness of life
so that you tell the people you love how
you feel about them so you write the
letters that need to be written and I
know people don't write letters but
writing a letter to someone you need to
express forgiveness to or gratitude to
is really powerful
pursue the projects that will allow you
to be the legend of your industry chase
the passions the fuel your joy and live
every day as if it was your last because
we never know when our last day will
show up
rule number 21 don't fit in the traits
that make you strange or the gifts that
make you special
and so I know you're different because
you wouldn't be here with me now he
didn't feel you're different
you probably don't fit in with most
conversations I sure don't fit in with
most conversations I don't know a lot
about most things that most people talk
about because I don't participate in the
majority right I don't participate in
the news I don't like to gossip I like
to encourage people versus diminish
people I like to be productive versus
busy I like to be creative versus
complacent I like to create value versus
take from other people I like to move
into my present and future versus get
stuck in the past I like to be fast
versus move too - too slow I like to be
a leader versus a victim I like to
believe in possibility versus get stuck
in rational thinking because you know
the instinct is so much more powerful
than intellect and all I'm suggesting to
you is simply this it's the very things
that make you different that make you
authentic and if you don't fit in I just
want to share with you
I've never fit in and the very nature of
anyone who's living a visionary life and
you are living a visionary life no
matter what you're doing let's look at
trapped in labels oh I'm just a coder
I'm just a receptionist in at a at a at
a restaurant or or in an organization
I'm just a yoga teacher I'm just a gym
manager I'm just a chef in a restaurant
so I'm just to teach you people always
say this when I interact with them on
the social media I'm just an
entrepreneur I'm just a student no
you're not I'm just a mom I'm just a dad
no you're not just you're very special
there are no extra people on the planet
today I just want to save you and
validate for you and encourage you those
things that other people might not get
those are your gifts you might be
awkward
awesome you see the world through a
different lens Steve Wozniak who was on
my stage at the Titan summit Zurich the
co-founder of Apple one of the best
people I've ever met he would not have
been able to create the Apple platforms
and products that had created if he
didn't see the world through a different
set of eyes Steve Jobs saw the world
through a different set of eyes Travis
kalanick
of uber saw the world through a
different set of eyes Jeff Bezos of
Amazon saw possibility let me have an
online store that initially sells books
John F Kennedy Martin Luther King jr.
mother Teresa Rose apart jean-michel
basquiat Beethoven Michelangelo who did
the Sistine Chapel and in Florence David
Yoda salt Tesla we could just go on and
on and on and on
these people were misunderstood because
the nature of a genius is to not fit in
rule number 22 hire a players Bill Gates
was asked what was the winning formula
of Microsoft when Microsoft was really
the heavyweight champion of their
industry I think they're a little lost
right now but the larger point again is
he replied with this what made Microsoft
Microsoft was not our software
what made Microsoft Microsoft was our
hiring I just want to suggest to you the
second point or trait of a world-class
company is their ability to hire a
players here is the brain tattoo I want
you to absolutely hardwired in to your
business philosophy as a leader you
cannot build an A level company with
c-level talent if your company is not
winning in your field right now you
likely have weaknesses in your hiring
don't just hire people because it's the
easiest move to make a lot of companies
spend very little time on hiring and
then most of third
I'm managing their hiring mistakes and
you know if you're building a business
if you're not reproduce a lot of the
people who watch these mastery sessions
and come to my live events you know I'm
speaking truth here so you really want
to nail your hiring rule number 23 let
go of your excuses
I've been evangelizing one particular
message for two decades and it's you can
lead without a title you know the
seduction of society is that you have to
have formal power to make a difference
and that's just a lie the world has sold
us the reality is you can lead without a
title and really the difference or the
defining trait of a leader is you shift
from victimhood see victims love making
excuses and if you recite your excuses
long enough you actually think they're
gonna be true I see it around the world
you know people saying these things like
I don't have time to run or I don't I'm
not good enough to be great of my work
or this would never work or I don't live
in the right country or a life is hard
and the more you recite those excuses
you think they're true so let go of your
excuses start getting some results done
and over time you're gonna rise to your
world-class rule number 24 deseed the
lemon wedges one of the things about the
95 percent a lot of them are complaining
they're making excuses they want epic
lives but they're stuck in the group of
soup the cult of superficiality the top
5% the titans the icons the a players
the world builders are very different
they are not about superficiality they
are all about granularity literally they
have deseeded the lemon wedges this is a
metaphor that I teach basically I was at
a at a hotel in Luzerne Switzerland and
I love fresh lemon tea and when they
brought the tray to me I noticed that in
the tray was two lemon halves or and
they someone in the kitchen had taken
the time to DC the lemon wedges they
actually deseeded them and when I study
f1 teams and I actually had the
privilege to be right with the tea
at a recent f1 and what I realized is f1
almost like no other sport is really
about deseeding the Levin wedges it was
the smallest granular detail the
smallest calibration that could make the
difference between a top one and a tenth
place finish I really want you to think
about that I really want to think about
f1 f1 is won or lost in milliseconds
because each lap if you get a little bit
faster and you do it with the
consistency because consistency is the
mother of mastery that is the difference
between first place and not even placing
and so if you look at the top five
percent they are all about deseeding the
lemon wedges if you look at the top five
percent they're all about calibration
and people might misunderstand you and
say are you obsessive why do the details
matter and all you have to do is smile
and say because the details matter
and if you study Beyonce study the great
athletes you study the great f1 drivers
and teams they do de-seed the lemon
wedges they do calibrate the Pomodoro
they get OAD that brain tattoo I've
become really well known across the
planet for an obsessive attention to
detail OAD that's what makes the best
hotels the best entrepreneurs the best
teams the market leaders the best
restaurants the best hotels the best
cars the best products the best user
experience is all in life they are
sweating the tiniest seemingly innocuous
innocuous details to create over time a
user experience that clay it creates a
go global base of fanatical followers
rule number 25 be comfortable in the
unknown one of my brain tattoos that I'm
become very well known for is no one
will believe in you until you believe in
you and so good people often become
seduced by the chatter of their loudest
fears and what I mean by that is we come
up with a great idea let's say it's to
start a project that will allow you to
lead your field let's say it's an idea
for a new product that
allow you to grow new company let's say
you come up with an idea for a new
painting if you are an artist let's say
it's an idea that will allow you to take
your fitness and your wellness and your
longevity to a whole new level of Wow
and pretty shortly after you come up
with the idea
your ego starts screaming because we are
good in our comfort zones but the moment
we start to go blue ocean around our
next level of mastery our fears come up
because we're going out into the unknown
it's human you know if you were looking
to look at the psycho biology of it and
you were study the pure biology that
there's a term called homeostasis human
beings are hard-wired for a steady state
and that kept us alive so literally our
heartbeats around the same amount you
know the 72 beats per minute
and our blood pressure is within a small
bandwidth and that allows us to survive
but what happens is when we come up with
a new idea and when we see a new
opportunity and we start to leave our
comfort zones into the zone of the
unknown where greatness lives we get
scared and the true heroes and the true
Titans and the true masters those people
are not fearless those are people who
have just practiced walking into their
fear and living on the razor's edge
consistently to the point where they're
comfortable amid their discomfort that's
the great opportunity for you not to
avoid fear but to be comfortable in the
unknown to be comfortable when you're
terrified and that really is what the
great artists the great entrepreneurs
the great titans and the great masters
are very good on doing so the first
reason good people lose is their faith
is not as strong as their fear or to put
it a bit more elegantly their fears are
larger than their faith and so it would
be tactical for you how do you build
more faith while you you do what you're
a frightened to do and it's a practice
you know a great athlete practices every
morning and a great producer practices
walking into their fears every single
day
and what I'm encouraging you to do is
every single day do one thing that
causes your palms to sweat every single
day start training your brain to hunt
for opportunities to step into that
unknown where possibility lives and if
you keep on doing it you're literally
gonna build some new neurological
hardwiring a new mental a new pathway in
your brain where you become it becomes
easier because as you know so well all
change is hard at first and it's messy
in the middle and it's beautiful at the
end remember 26 only release magic you
want to if you want to have a
world-class company release only magic
another way I could put it only release
Sistine Chapel ceiling level products to
the world Steve Jobs said it beautifully
he said I wanted the icons on the iPhone
to be so beautiful people would want to
lick the screen I had a senior leader
show up at one of my leadership events
and he said you know Robin Steve Jobs
was like that I actually went to his
house and met him shortly before he died
and he didn't look very well but he
didn't want to talk about his physical
condition he just wanted to talk about
the product we were launching he was so
mono maniacally focused on the user
experience he literally wanted to
everything to be flawless that was Steve
Jobs as brilliance and obsession I saw
an incredible interview with Johnny I've
by Charlie Rose in in that Johnny I've
who you know is the design genius behind
a lot of the Apple products he said you
know I knew Steve Jobs and I were
spiritual brothers when we were in a
store one day and Steve Jobs said to me
he goes hey come on over Johnny you got
to see this and I believe from the
interview I believe this is what they
said but they were looking at an arrow
and Steve Jobs said look at how the
sharp point of the arrow is attached to
this part and look how seamless it is
and look at the engineering and our one
how they did that and Johnny I've said
Steve Jobs was just in the pocket of the
engineering and beauty behind that piece
of artistry
they were looking at rule number 27 used
the 1991 rule so for the next 90 days
your first 90 minutes at work make it
focused on your single most important
project I'll repeat that again for the
next 90 days the first 90 minutes of
your work day focus monomaniacal e on
your single most valuable project I call
it your game changing move so it might
be it might be creating a new piece of
code that will revolutionize the
marketplace it might be a new product
that when you launch it will fill a need
within your industry that no peer is
currently providing I don't know what
your game changing move is but this is
your poetry this is your magnum opus for
the next 90 days so what most people do
is you know people who are playing at
victimhood people who are in the ninety
five percent people who are making
excuses about ordinary results in their
life a lot of them are not doing the
things that would give them legendary
results and what they do is they get to
the office and rather than using prime
time for a activities they use their
best hours watching dancing cats on
whatever it is whatever the video
platform is they spend their best hours
surfing the internet looking at blogs
they spend their best hours playing with
notifications reading notifications
chatting with friends who are not really
their friends but really they're just
bored so they were distracting
themselves which is just a form of
medication because potential unexpressed
turns to pain and they're in a lot of
pain and it's subconscious and they
haven't done the work to know it so
really they've created these drugs of
choice like too much email too much web
surfing too much chit chatting too much
looking at funny-looking videos that
make them laugh in the moment that make
them feel happy
give them a short burst of dopamine and
maybe a little bit of serotonin which is
the pleasure neurotransmitter and that's
how they get through their day and all
I'm saying is there's so much
distraction available to you out there
that if you are not acutely careful it
will dominate your days what I'm really
trying to say is this a ritual for you
to run and dial in and hardwire to the
point of automaticity that's the word
the researchers use when a habit becomes
your new normal
over 66 days is the 1991 rule and to
give it to you again so you really
remember it for the next 90 days your
first 90 minutes create a tight bubble
of total focus so that no one can
distract you turn off your devices put
them in a little plastic bag put some
reminders on your door maybe some
post-it notes that this is my type
bubble of total focus for the next 90
minutes tell your team tell your loved
ones maybe get it put a Do Not Disturb
sign on your door they'll laugh and
explain it to them that for the next 90
days I will spend 90 minutes away from
distraction away from technology away
from interruptions focusing on my magnum
opus focusing on the genius project that
I want to bring into the world because I
will never mail it in I will always
bring it on and I'm gonna do this for
the next 90 minutes and I'm gonna
optimize it and iterate it every day and
I'm gonna bring my full bandwidth
because what makes a genius they all
have one trait in common they were able
to spend extended periods of time in
isolation focused mono maniacally on
their most valuable project rule number
28 become a valuable person well you've
heard me talk about the 2 X 3 X mindset
so to double your income and your impact
triple your investment including your
time investment in two core areas your
personal mastery and your professional
capabilities you see when you work on
your personal mastery you awaken
your mind set your heart set your health
set in your soul set and when you get
those four interior
empires to world class you become a
force of nature out in the world and you
do epic things so you want to work on
your personal mastery like you're doing
here with me right now by listening to
this episode and then the second thing
you want to do is you want to work on
your professional capability you want to
be the heavyweight champion of your game
you want to dial in your sport whether
your sport is entrepreneurship whether
your sport is being a chef whether your
sport is being a coder whether your
sport is being a manager whether you're
an entrepreneur a CEO and astronaut a
poet I don't know what it is but when
you focus on your personal mastery and
your professional capability and you
really work on those I'm talking about
hours every day if you are serious about
leading the field what starts to happen
is this you become a vastly more
valuable person you become very aware
and that's why I say education is
inoculation against disruption that's
why I suggest you with great love and
respect leadership belongs to the
learners Maya Angelou said it
beautifully she said when you know
better you can do better with better
awareness you can make better choices
and with better choices you're gonna see
better results I mean it's the awareness
that you bring to everyday based on your
learning based on your investments in
training well what does that do it gives
you the ability to a to make better
choices better decisions when you look
at a great life it's just a series of
beautiful choices done daily stacked on
over time and so when you get great
awareness heightened awareness or acute
awareness of what it means to be a
leader an elite performer and a player
an awesome human being an epic producer
a fit human being a loving human it just
goes it on would that awareness via your
learning you can make better decisions
every day better choices
rule number 29 learn to say no what
makes a great company is less about
you're good opportunities and a lot more
about you having the bravery and
discipline to say no to you to your many
good opportunities what destroys a great
company is actually opportunity bloating
too many good opportunities so literally
you diffuse your team's bandwidth and
you get distracted and you see with so
many companies right now
they they sort of found their sweet
pocket and they were absolutely winning
in their marketplace and they decided to
go hmm we've got this app that is really
changing the game and owning the
marketplace let's get into food delivery
let's get into this let's get into that
it happened to General Electric as well
you probably know they decided at one
point if we can't be one or two in any
market we're gonna get out of that
market that's the key point I'm trying
to make no you're mighty mission no your
monomaniacal focus and then have the
discipline to say no to everything else
so you can lock and load on your finest
opportunity to completely change the
game rule number 30 make your eye cane
larger than your IQ I remember being in
Soho New York and I walked into one of
the stories and I bought a coat and I
was leaving on an airplane for home
later that day and I asked the person
who was taking care of me I said is it
possible that's a great respectful way
to ask for something is it possible to
get this coat hemmed and adjust it a
little bit for me and he and and I said
the thing is that I'm leaving later
today and he looked at me and I've never
forgotten it because we all have these
people in our lives who say one thing or
show up in a certain way and they stay
with us for the rest of their lives and
he said to me these words he said it I'd
love to do that for you I'd love to do
that for you and again the whole brain
type - I'm trying to deconstruct here is
make your I can larger than your eye
you you know I remember being in Prague
and I asked someone on the other again I
spent a lot of time in hotels and I said
is it possible to do this and here was
the reply on the other end of the phone
I think was someone from the front desk
or maybe it was room service and I try
to eat as clean as possible so probably
it was a request could I have olive oil
and fresh lemon or lemon as the salad
dressing and here's the reply just
really lovingly and respectfully and
hopefully fluently and elegantly bring
this leadership inside home to you I
said is this possible and his reply was
anything is possible so it's really easy
to get seduced and stuck into a mindset
of can't you know someone says let's
start a new business someone says here's
a great poetic project that if we
release it to the world
will help us own our marketplace and it
sounds very obvious again but ask
yourself this is your default reply a
symptom of a mindset of can't or do you
have a mentality of possibility when
someone says here read this book do you
shift into can't or can when someone
says hey you know what I'm amped to run
a marathon you go I can't is that your
default setting in your neurobiological
hardwiring or do you go absolutely or I
love to do this you know it's really
really important and that is one of the
core distinctions of leadership isn't it
rule number 31 lead thyself I'm gonna
get right into the first rule which is
leader lead thyself so leadership is not
just for CEOs leadership is not just for
prime ministers and presidents and
people with large bank accounts and
massive offices leadership is not only
an opportunity but the responsibility of
every man woman and child on the planet
today no matter what it is you do
whether you're a filmmaker a startup
entrepreneur a manager of a corporation
bread creator or whatever it's got a
baker I guess there'll be a baker
whether you're a teacher whether a
firefighter whether you're a politician
whether you are a gardener whether you
are a wall maker I don't know whatever
it is you do but every day you walk out
in the world gives you not only that
opportunity but brings with it the
awesome responsibility to show up as a
leader because leadership really isn't a
title you know my book the leader I had
no title you've probably read it
leadership is less about a title and
it's more about an approach a way of
being and some of the traits of leaders
without titles the radiant optimists in
a world gone cynical one of the things
about leaders without titles they don't
see their job as a job they see their
job as a craft no matter what their work
is they understand there's dignity in
all labor one of the traits of leaders
without titles they are relentlessly
improving everything they touch so they
leave it better than they found it and
so the first rule for a monumental life
is simply leader lead thyself which just
means see yourself as a leader and don't
wait for the people around you to start
leading lead where you're planted lead
by example you stand up first be an army
of one when it comes to leadership and
spreading that leadership possibility
around you rule number 30 to have
clarity clarity is the DNA of mastery so
if you look at the Titans of business
the true leaders in finance these people
literally will say look at my charts
they if you look at a great military
leader you look at a great athlete
they have such granular in a world of
superficiality they have shifted to
massive granularity so they know in the
intimate detail exactly what their
future timeline will look like why
because clarity Bri
and builds and is the DNA of mastery you
want to have a very clear vision of what
your future is going to look like and
when you know in intimate detail what
your future will look like then you
automatically subconsciously as well as
consciously you can say no to the
important so you say a giant yes to the
few things that are most important
you've heard me share this before
Confucius said it so well first the
person who chases two rabbits catches
neither
and so what I'm encouraging you to do is
this exercise before you go to sleep
tonight let's make this very tactical I
call it the 100-year timeline on a
single page a single page from where you
now are 100 years out into your ideal
future I want you every single milestone
on a single line to say here's where I
now am
here's what's gonna happen next week
next month next quarter next year three
years five years ten years 25 years 50
years 75 years one year 100 years until
you have a 100 year timeline on the
other side of the piece of paper with
crayons so you tap into your part of the
brain responsible for creativity your
right brain okay with crayons draw out
your ideal family life draw up one year
away draw out your business life one
year away draw out your adventure life
one year out into the future draw out
your financial life draw out your
material life literally on a page with
crayons so you're not thinking because
here's a I think a needle moving insight
world-class comes from instinct versus
intelligence you get your best ideas
when you get out of your thinking and
just to give you some neuroscience the
seed of reasoning is the prefrontal
cortex but there's a phenomenon I teach
in my live events called transient
hypofrontality this is the secret of
genius geniuses don't get their ideas
for
Amazon the electric bulb Tesla
Shakespeare the polio vaccination SpaceX
great ideas don't come from the
intellect 'they they don't come from the
neocortex reasoning and thinking all
great heroes and great inventors and
great creators dialed into something
deeper when you get out of your
neocortex through solitude and my life
structure that I teach called the tight
bubble of total focus and when you get
away from distraction and you immerse
yourself in deep creativity and creation
and you find your laboratory or what I
call your Menlo Park like Edison it is
Menlo Park which was with the wilderness
away from the world what happens the
prefrontal cortex it's silent and it's
called transient transient which means
temporary transient hypo small
frontality the neocortex the seat in
your brain of thinking actually shuts
down for a short period of time
this is profound information and will
confirm your brain is built for genius
but if you don't do the right things
you're not going to be able to allow the
genius to see the light of day rule
number 33 master your inner self you
might have a great mindset positive
thinking but if you have a heart set
full of anger if your emotional life is
sad if you're disappointed from the past
if you haven't done that the sweat
lodges and the journaling and the
bodywork and the affirmations to really
open up a heart set then you can have
the mindset a little Elon Musk you can
have the mindset of a Steve Jobs you can
have a mindset of a Kobe but you're
gonna sabotage yourself from world class
and to me this is the great myth of
positive thinking you see a lot of
people they read all books they're
positive thinkers they've got the vision
boards nothing changes why because
subconsciously there's this wounding and
a lack of deserve ability and it's
unconscious and so they haven't done the
worker you may have not done the work to
make the wounds of underserved bility
and scarcity and
low self-worth that's why positive
thinking alone does not work this is to
me a revolutionary insight and by the
way a lot of the people who teach
positive thinking in the past our men so
it's very male mind and a lot of the
people who are pioneers of heart said
are women heart empathy healing and so
self mastery to me and this is a
pioneering model that I teach at
personal mastery Academy it's not just
mindset that's only 25 percent of self
mastery and as you know self mastery is
the DNA of outer mastery you're never
going to perform higher than what's
going on within mindset is only 25%
heart set your emotional life working
from confidence and love and service and
that sense of internal freedom is only
another 25 percent that so those who are
only 50 percent there's a third interior
Empire you want to get to world class
which is health set working on your
energy your nutrition your daily
exercise hacking your longevity eating
the right supplements getting a massage
every to which you know my to massage
protocol doing your 60 minute nature
walk every week so that your health set
is at world-class but that's only 75
percent of the equation towards self
mastery you can have a great mindset
great heart set great health set but if
you haven't worked on your soul set
turning down your ego you know you know
what disease and what energy depletion
is caused by your ego beating you
relentlessly about you not being enough
and seeing your industry peers
succeeding and you feel insecure and
irritated and angry and jealous well
where do you do that work within your
soul set the forth into your empire and
as you do that you turn down the ego and
you open up your humanity and you open
up your spirit
Oh life and you become more soulful and
then you release work that is artistry
versus just to win in the next few
months when you literally give your life
over to a mighty mission that is larger
than your ego and you literally start to
see your work as a ministry for the
benefit of humanity and if you literally
if you're an artist or an entrepreneur
or CEO manager or coder a doctor a
fighter firefighter but literally if you
saw your work as your poetry and your
artistry and you were on a mighty
mission that was larger than even your
your ego and yourself what would the
caliber of your output be rule number 34
through thine own self be true rule
number four to thine own self be true
you're gonna say Robin that sounds sort
of familiar of course a Shakespeare to
thine own self be true you know Oscar
Wilde said it's so much more elegantly
than I ever could he said be yourself
everyone else is taken you know Jack
Welsh when he was a general electric one
of our clients GE he said never lose
yourself on the way to the top
wow what amazing advice for you and me
never lose yourself on the way to the
top to them to thine own self be true
never betray your authenticity never
lose your boots on the ground didn't
assign self be true means as you make
your rise to legendary don't forget what
makes you great hardwork humility
serving your customers working on your
craft playing the long game
understanding the genius takes decades
versus good genetics rule number 35 just
start the bow to tightly strung is
easily broken says one of the Proverbs
balance is a gorgeous thing
so be monomaniacal in your execution
around your high-value targets your HV
tees
mission plan but also build in some
rewards and that's gonna send a gorgeous
message to your conscious and your
subconscious mind that hey this daily
practice of execution around my
deliverables is a beautiful thing
and you create this thing called
momentum and the monk who sold his
Ferrari how went back and I saw this
recently that I think there's a whole
chapter on momentum and you become like
this I love skiing you start off small
but as you go down the slope you pick up
momentum a lot of people say Robin where
do I start I want to start a new
business I want to become a better
artist I want to find the love of my
life I want to be a world-class creative
I want to multiply my financial life
where do I start you just start you just
start there's great power in the start
and when you start life starts
supporting you rule number 36 master the
skill of communication most leaders most
business people most entrepreneurs most
human beings have never learned to be
masterful communicators and the very
nature of influence and impact which is
the leaders job is communication I mean
in school where you given a
communication course very few people
have been taught that in your personal
relationships have you read books on
communication well that leads to I mean
in in an intimate relationship or even
just with a friend it's the little
miscommunications that over time stack
into loss in your intimate relationships
it's the little conversations that you
could have had in five minutes if you
have the tools to communicate and the
awareness to speak so literally you
could release the anger and build
understanding and speak out your needs
and feel the need to be heard all those
little things if you had learned how to
do that over and done it in five minutes
with your intimate partner you might not
have lost the relationship and in your
profession
life learning to communicate inspires
your teammates you know if you look at
the great leaders of humanity the Nelson
Mandela is the mother theresa's for
Martin Luther King Junior's the john f
kennedy's if you look at the great
business builders Steve Jobs great
example right he would be on the stage
at the product launch and then that
favorite line one more thing and that's
when he would reveal the latest piece of
technology that would create industry
dominance when Steve Jobs was at Apple
well he was a masterful communicator and
Bud Tribble over at Apple called it his
reality distortion field Steve Jobs was
a master salesman he knew exactly what
to say to get people to believe in the
impossible to allow their I can't to be
less valuable than their I can't rule
number 37 serve with our customers my
team runs a protocol called at an x
value obsession how can we deliver ten
times the value at every single touch
point of the user experience that our
customers come to the live events or go
into my online course or even read my
books are expecting their they pay
twenty dollars for a book or thirty
dollars for a book how can I give them
millions of dollars of real value
someone said to me recently in your
mastery sessions you're giving away the
store or something like that you know
like I sort of can't believe how much
value you give and my reply was because
my intent is to serve I mean this is not
a business for me yes I run a business
and a series of businesses I'm an
entrepreneur but the point really is my
intent is so much larger than that I'm
on a mission bordering on an obsession
to help everyday people understand the
neurobiology of greatness and they can
lead without a title if you've read my
book the leader had no title that they
have hero wisdom in them and then giving
them the neuroscience the research the
performance data that will help them win
in their careers live
rate lives live their potential this is
so much more than a business for me and
this comes from value number two I see
this as a movement a sense of community
a sense of giving a sense of helping you
fortify the genius within you in a very
difficult world so you say huh Robin has
giving me thousands of ideas in these
free mastery sessions that I can choose
to act on every day to go out there and
fire proof my heroism so I can do great
work that Wow's the world do great
things for my family and leave an impact
on history that stands the test of time
and if I do that in my own way that I've
served you and I've done my job well
rule number 38 get great at your craft
eighth rule for a monumental life is get
great at your craft
look you have a gargantuan competitive
advantage because most people are caught
up or card-carrying members and I say
this with respect buts reporting reality
most people in the world right now in
business are card-carrying members of
the cult of mediocrity in a previous
episode and I share this in my
leadership presentations I believe the
world today is suffering and that word
I'm choosing it consciously and
carefully from the collective deep
professionalization of business a little
while ago I was in an airport there was
a elevator repairman and he had his
boombox cranking out hard rock well
that's fine but he's at work he's not at
home I go into a store these days there
are people listening to music out loud
when they should be taking care of
customers you walk into an airport and
you see people behind the desk or
whatever
rather than being pros owning the game
you literally see them chit-chatting or
again looking at videos of dancing cats
and people riding bicycles off the roofs
of their houses you know what I'm
talking about I call it the collective
deep professionalization of business
very few people relatively speaking
right now say this is my craft I've got
to be a pro I've got to study the
audiobooks that relate to my game I've
got a fine Mentors I've got to read the
books I've got to practice like Federer
or Serena Williams or Muhammad Ali used
to practice you know a Muhammad Ali once
said he said I hated every single one of
those early morning runs but I loved the
idea of being champion of the world
rule number 39 on your day and then
before you go to sleep ask yourself this
question did I live out my plan for
today
your days are your life and miniature
all you need to do is not worry about
the next week the next month the next
year forget about that that's a waste of
time
own your day your days are your life and
miniature as you live each day so you
craft the rest of your life and the day
slip into weeks the weeks become months
the months become years before you know
it you've lived a legendary life because
all you did was dial into gorgeous
brilliant productive creative loving
healthy soulful days your days are the
pockets and instruments of genius get
those right your life will take care of
itself remember 40 are the genius within
you don't live your life on the outside
to fill these holes on the inside that
you haven't filled start the interior
work of self-mastery to fill the holes
so your mindset heart set health set and
soul set are full and then you'll feel
joy when you wake up every morning and
you'll work not for the money but for
the meaning and you'll create with a
fire in your belly that will make you
undefeatable it's not because you're
pursuing income is because you're
pursuing impact in craft and love of you
honoring the genius within you d do you
see what I'm referring to your outer
life you still might work hard I love
working hard I love it but I'm not doing
it for the money
I'm doing it because of Who I am I have
to write I have to surf I have to use
the rest of my life
to be an instrument of impact for as
many people as possible
remember 41 be a leader leadership is
much less a title and much more an
approach to going through life and so
when you walk out in the world every day
I just want you to keep that in mind as
much as possible you can behave like a
leader with which is assuming personal
responsibility for your results or it
can be like a victim which is something
bad happens or something doesn't quite
work out and you give away your power
and you blame and you complain and you
become toxic and right now the world has
far too many victims people who are
rather than looking in the mirror saying
I have the power to change and I might
not like where I'm at in my work right
now or in my life or in my health or in
my love or in my spirituality but I have
the power to change well victims say I
might not be where I'm at in the world
but it's because of the world it's
because of my childhood is because of my
husband my wife my boss my team my
country my economy and so my loving
encouragement to you is ask yourself
right now am i behaving like a victim
maybe it's in your health life maybe
it's with your finances you know and a
victim would be saying you know I can't
do this that's what victims do I can't
do this or victims they point fingers
well it's the economy where I live right
now or it's the industry it's going
through a lot of commoditization and a
lot of disruption and if I was in a
different industry I'd be successful
ultimately we all know this we create a
reality and even in the most difficult
and most competitive of industries there
are people who are playing at
world-class who are doing really well
why because they have a different
approach because they're doing different
things and fundamentally they're not
behaving like victims blaming and
complaining and being toxic and wasting
time and living in the past they're
showing up like leaders
so be a leader and all that you do today
rule number 42 define your values step
number two in the process of structuring
or creating this world-class life your
five non-negotiable values really
important to look at your values what
are values values are what you're going
to value as you go through your days as
you go through your weeks as you go
through your life values could be what a
mine I value beauty so I want to be
around Beauty as much as possible I love
art galleries I love nature I love
sunset I love looking at the Stars I
love beautiful foods simply prepared
with people who I love I love beautiful
conversations I love beautiful books
because a home with a large library is a
wonderful home to be in so step number
two in this process to set yourself up
for a spectacular life what are your
five non-negotiables Ollie's maybe it's
you'll be around beauty everyday maybe
it's no matter what the situation is I
will always live with integrity maybe
one of your non-negotiable values will
be I will exercise even what I don't
feel like it
maybe one of your non-negotiable values
will be family first I don't know these
are just some things that I want you to
think about rule number 43 put out
legendary work a legendary takes time
and you can find yourself a gargantuan
competitive advantage where you say I'm
going to think long term I'm going to
play the long game I understand the
genius and world-class and legendary is
not a sprint it's a marathon and when
you do that you start to raise your
level of awareness can you see her job
as a craft not just a job and you start
to say I'm not gonna put anything out
into the world that is less than Steve
Jobs level you know Steve Jobs really
wasn't an entrepreneur he really didn't
care much about the money Steve Jobs
really was an artist and you've probably
heard me share this before but there's
the great story about
in the mid-1980s Steve Jobs said we're
gonna launch the first Apple Macintosh
and he said you know I want this
computer to be revolutionary and when I
interviewed Steve Wozniak the co-founder
and Steve Jobs Jobs his partner and a
Titan summit in Zurich a little while
ago I heard this firsthand that Steve
Wozniak wanted to create computers that
were just industry that would shake up
the status quo that was his obsession he
wanted to do things no one else no other
coder could do and he told me Steve Jobs
was an artist and so in the mid 1980s
Steve Jobs got his design team around
him and here's what he told them this is
the deliverable guys I want this first
Apple Macintosh to be so beautiful it
brings tears to people's eyes but the
real deliverable is I want the inside to
be art and the design team said well
Steve no one's gonna look inside the
computer no one's going to open it up
why not just we just focus on a
world-class user experience on the
outside and beautiful architecture and
design and he said no this is what I
want and so when his design team went to
work and the engineering team went to
work they literally said we've got to
deliver on Steve cz's obsession and when
Steve Jobs first saw that Apple
Macintosh when it was produced he
started to cry because he saw the beauty
of execution around his vision and then
we saw the inside he was moved deeply
because Steve Jobs wasn't an
entrepreneur it was much more an artist
and they looked at his design team and
he said now I want you to sign the
circuit board and they said why and he
said because all artists sign their work
I don't know what you do I don't know
where you live one thing I know for sure
maybe the world has not told you you are
an artist but I encourage you see your
work and anything you produce as poetry
and your Nate your good name is on what
you're releasing to the world and rather
than putting out a lot of poetry and a
lot of work why not put out less work
but work that is legendary
rule number 44 have a higher mission
society right now is defining success by
how much you have but mothma Gandhi died
with less than ten possessions I mean he
had a spinning wheel he had his
eyeglasses I believe he had a watch and
a few other things mother Teresa I was
actually in her mission in cold Kolkata
in India and I went into her her bedroom
and all she had was a very Spartan bed
and a desk and if you look at Martin
Luther King jr. these people all lived
very Spartan lives in very sparse lives
why because they really didn't care
about accumulating things they were on a
monomaniacal mission to free the
population that they were serving it's
not about accumulating things if you
really want to be a hero of history
it's about finding some kind of fiery
cause that fuels your passion and that
brings on your talent for the benefit of
helping as many people as possible and
in my work I call that a cause in my
work I call that a monomaniacal mission
and you know you don't have to be a
Nelson Mandela or a mother Teresa to
live like this you can be a
schoolteacher who says you know what
here's the the higher mission I want to
dedicate the rest of my career to and
it's educating young people to believe
in themselves and to capitalize on their
on their skills so they do great things
in their lives and they're Afeni fits
the world you could be a baker and
understand that you know what your cause
could be every single person who comes
in this bakery I will leave them better
than I found them because every day is
an opportunity to lift another human
being into radiates optimism and to
model possibility you could be a taxi
driver you could be a firefighter I
don't know what you do but the
difference between a victim and a leader
is a victim sees a job as a job and a
leader sees a job as a cause and that
really is a game-changing insight if you
say you know what I might not be leading
millions but I am leading a team at the
office or I am leading my family or I'm
I'm not leading anyone but I'm a human
being
and I have the capacity to walk out into
the world and in a world where a lot of
people are closed and a lot of people
are negative and a lot of people have
walls you can stand for possibility and
you can stand for high energy and you
can stand for hope and you can stand for
love and that's a really profound
responsibility and opportunity you have
on your shoulders today rule number 45
execute you're like a Navy SEAL you've
got the mission plan now you execute it
here's the key the more you do difficult
things the more you'll be brilliant at
doing difficult things you get better at
what you practice if you complain you're
going to be Picasso level of complaining
if you eat bad food in terms of your
nutritional plan every day you're
literally gonna hardwire the neural
circuits so that you become Roger
Federer level and eating bad food if
you're a victim or a toxic person or
what people call a drama mama and that
applies to men and women and if you do
it every day
for 10,000 hours Thank You Anders
Ericsson who did the research on the
10,000 hour rule you're gonna be f1
driver f1 champion driver level
performance at being a drama mama
if you cut corners in your craft at work
every day you are literally hardwiring
in and practicing and if you practice it
over ten years 10,000 hours in total
you're gonna be Mozart level Shakespeare
level Elon Musk level Richard Branson
level Steve Wozniak level Shaq level
Kobe level
at that practicing mediocrity you will
get brilliant at what you practice every
day consciously and subconsciously rule
number 46 honor your gift manage the
downside all genius has a dark side so
whether it's a Beethoven or a Buffett
whether it's a Federer or Serena
Williams whether it is a jean-michel
Basquiat or a Ferran adrià the things
that allow for genius all have a
downside or a dark side here's some
examples someone who is absolutely
brilliant at execution has a dark side
to manage of impatience someone like
Steve Jobs who is a fanatical
perfectionist could be seen as demanding
someone who is amazingly creative could
self-sabotage with too many ideas the
key is this honor your gift manage the
downside rule number 47 manage your
maturity level the vast majority of
people what they do is they are pursuing
things they derive their power by what
they have in the world they want they
measure success by more money and a
larger house and a faster car and more
social status but if you look at the
so-called great ones the history makers
who have shaped humanity they really are
in an alternate universe or another
orbit they're really not fueled by the
things that most people are chasing when
I look at a Nelson Mandela for example
what I've realized is through their
interior work you know my for interior
empires mindset heart set health set and
soul set and so through his interior
work to build his interior and internal
character Nelson Mandela got to a level
of maturity that most people just don't
get to why because most people are so
outer focused and building exterior
lives and it's not so hip and cool and
stylish anymore to build
asked and undefeatable interior lives
but he did when maybe it was a lot of
his time through the suffering of 27
years of incarceration maybe it was the
18 years that he spent in isolation on
Robben Island the point really is
through his personal excavation through
his reflection through his prayer
through his contemplation for so many
years he built a vast interior reservoir
of strength and creativity and true
versus fake power that created an inner
life of incredible maturity and so the
first point really is do whatever it
takes to build a life of such maturity
where it's not about your ego but it's
about lifting the world and that's
incredibly powerful because if you base
your power on things should you lose
those things you lose your power you're
in a really vulnerable place but if you
derive your power and your self-worth
and your sense of self from who you are
your moral authority your sense of
creativity your your ability to love
yourself your knowledge of the fullness
of the gifts that you were born into if
that's where your identity comes from
then your world could fall apart and you
still say you stay strong so first point
work on your maturity level so you get
to a place where it's not about me it's
about we work on your maturity so you're
not deriving your strengthen the world
from external things but you're getting
it from your internal character or your
internal life rule number 48 don't blame
others
I've never responsibilities didn't
manage yourself you know sometimes
people say well my boss is grumpy and
cranky and doesn't really appreciate me
one of the key ideas is people don't
leave companies they leave the people
they worked with you've heard that
before
that's not
my idea that's out there but the point
on lead or lead thyself is you're
responsible for managing your mind set
your heart set your health set your soul
set every time you blame your boss or
your husband or your wife your past or
your children the economy or your
nationality you're giving away your
power to be the change you want to see
to use the words of mahathma gandhi rule
number 49 architect a world-class life
in a world with a lot of people where a
lot of business people a lot of leaders
a lot of your friends what needs to
happen next year for this to be the best
year of your professional life your
personal life your financial life your
physical life your spiritual life your
love life I don't know most people spend
a lot more time on their summer
vacations a lot more time flipping
through the social media versus
architecting a world class life you want
to be one of those rare few you know my
brain tattoo to have the results only 5%
of the population have you've got to be
willing to do what 95% of the population
are unwilling to do and one of those
things don't be superficial don't live
it live a superficial life don't have a
superficial game plan fireproof yourself
against superficiality and really
understand this concept I've been
teaching called granularity when I work
with the NBA athletes who come into my
rooms at my events when I work with the
titans the billionaires the celebrity
CEOs you read about these people are
anything but superficial they are
granular and you can call them obsessed
you can call them obsessive you can call
them weird freaks coops misfits so what
call them what you want that's just a
label I'm reporting on reality these are
people who'll say let me show you my
battle plan for the next 80 days in the
next five years and rule number 50 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is live under the Ten Lost come up
with ten laws you are going to spend or
you're gonna live the remainder of your
life under that could be one of the
things I teach in my work don't die
one of the secrets to legendary is
longevity so outlive your industry peers
it's amazing what happens when you get
into such great physical health that you
just outlive everyone around you you
know it's 90 you're 90 no you have no
competition imagine how easy it will be
for you to dominate your field imagine
how good you're gonna be if you're a
hundred and three still rockin your game
so the point is don't die protect your
health hack aging eat the right
supplements workout every day get you
know run my to massage protocol make
sure you get fresh air the point is
simply this one of your ten life laws
could simply be don't die one of your
ten life laws could be give more than
you take one of your ten life laws could
be spend an hour alone building your
self relationship you know I was reading
Marcus Aurelius very early this morning
the great Roman Emperor and he talked
about the shortness of life but he also
talked about this find some time
everyday to be amid tranquility so you
could think see when you're in the noise
you can't think the noise of distraction
and attraction and diversion by
technology when you're alone and I found
it's the best thing first thing in the
morning you can actually think about
your values and you can actually get to
know yourself again and you can actually
breathe and you can actually contemplate
what am I gonna do today how am I gonna
live how can I make today on earth a
valuable day now I've got a special
bonus tip on how to block out the noise
that I really think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we
question number one what legendary work
will you put out this week number two
what do you just need to start on and
number three what excuse are you gonna
let go of today you know you're not very
smart or you can't do that if you're a
teacher and you say you know what you
can never be an astronaut
you can never be an empire maker you're
not smart enough to do this and some
teachers said that to me along my
journey you'll never you'll never finish
University and just to share the reality
I not only finished university with a
science degree but I did a law degree
and then a master's of law degree and I
only share that which is I haven't had
it easy I've been put down I have had
teachers who didn't see my potential
that's just reality you want to block
out the noise and listen to the signal
which is you're built to be a
possibility Rhian you're built to be
great
you have genius within you so calibrate
your languaging so your words to
yourself are world class if you want to
see some of Robins charmers best
productivity tips go check out the link
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy the video continue to believe and
I'll see you there I mean the Spartan
warriors said it so well sweat more in
training bleed lessen war and if you
want to be